[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue au parlement européen
à bruxelles pour un nouveau numéro d'
europe hebdo c'est une petite révolution
vendredi entre en vigueur le 1er gp dès
le règlement général pour la protection
des données textes européens pour mieux
protéger nos données numériques visait
entre autres par ce texte les gaffes à
google apple facebook amazon à ces
sociétés américaines du numérique qui
sont entrés dans nos vies de façon
insidieuse des fois l'europe leur
reproche de confisquer à leur profit les
données numériques personnelles des
utilisateurs à la riposte c'est le rg
qui concerne pas seulement à legata et
concerne aussi votre commerçant votre
banque votre patron les ressources
humaines bref ça touche les gens dans
leur vie quotidienne c'est important
qu'est ce qui va changer exactement on
veut en parler avec nos invités nous ont
rejoints sur ce plateau eva joly bonjour
d'enchaîner députée européenne du groupe
des verts ici au parlement européen le
groupe des verts qui est un peu la
russie à l'origine de cette
réglementation à vous même vous êtes
très appliqué à sur les problèmes du
numérique tant sur la fiscalité que sur
les données personnelles merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation jean arthuis
bonjour bonjour député européen du
groupe de l'alliance des démocrates et
libéraux pour l'europe ancien ministre
de l'économie merci d'avoir accepté mon
invitation enfin christine revault
d'allonnes bonjour vous êtes députée
européenne du groupe des socialistes et
démocrates merci d'être venu mais avant
cap sur l'actu cap sur l'italie l'italie
pays fondateurs du projet européen
deuxième industrie en europe devant la
france derrière l'allemagne l'italie ou
la liga la droite souverainiste est le
mouvement 5 étoiles se marient
définitivement ils ont présenté un
contrat pour un gouvernement de
changement
en fait c'est plus une compilation des
mesures voulues par chacun que
l'approché politique articulée avec
quand même un ennemi commun l'europe de
bruxelles on regarde et on réagit juste
après
[Musique]
ce mariage à l'italienne entre la ligue
et le mouvement 5 étoiles c'est un peu
le mariage de la carpe et du lapin
c'est aussi un programme commun révélé
vendredi dernier est actée par les deux
formations
sur le plan économique d'abord le
programme promet de combler les déficits
avec une politique de croissance
il prévoit des baisses drastiques
d'impôts l'instauration d'un revenu pour
tous
l'abaissement de l'âge de la retraite
dans le deuxième pays le plus vieux du
monde est aussi une fermeté inédite
contre la corruption une nationaux nien
personne ne doit craindre une politique
économique qui seront très différentes
de celles des dernières années qui ont
fait augmenter la dette publique de 300
milliards d'euros
notre objectif est de faire croître
l'économie italienne pour réduire la
dette
sur le plan intérieur c'est un tour de
vis sécuritaire un programme anti islam
et anti migrants le futur gouvernement
annonce vouloir renvoyer chez eux cinq
cent mille migrants débarqués de
méditerranée et ce en un an seulement
aujourd'hui les expulsions se fondre au
rythme de six mille cinq cents par an
même en quadruplant ce chiffre annuel
il faudrait plus de 20 ans à l'italie
pour expulser plus de 500 mille migrants
je veux aussi le dire au niveau
international laissez-nous commencé à
gouverner ensuite si vous voulez
critiquer nous mais laissez-nous
commencé notre travail
et voici l'italie la troisième économie
de l'union qui avancent en terrain connu
avec un personnel politique mêlant
amateurisme démagogie et radicalité pour
la première fois dans l'histoire de
l'union l'un de ses piliers bascule dans
le camp de lentilles système un défi
majeur pour l'europe qui va devoir gérer
une nouvelle crise interne d'une toute
autre ampleur que l'épisode grec
keystone redonne à la ligue de matteo
salvini elles vont manquer toile de
luigi di maio ont passé un contrat de
gouvernement l'a vu dans le reportage
vous êtes inquiète plus qu'inquiète
c'est vraiment une catastrophe
nous avions déjà connu la hongrie la
pologne l'autriche et maintenant
l'italie
nous commençons à avoir trop de pays
trop de membres du conseil qui sont sur
des positions anti européennes sur des
positions sur lesquels ils ont gagné des
élections avec des mensonges infamant
concernant les réfugiés
c'est extrêmement préoccupant et ça nous
interroge réellement sur la façon dont
nous allons devoir porter l'union
européenne demain gardez les traités
constant avec cette règle de l'unanimité
au conseil avec dé tels représentants
c'est une vraie catastrophe
jean arthuis sur le plan économique un
l'équipe gouvernementale en italie veut
s'affranchir des politiques d'austérité
européenne afin de plaire à ses
électeurs comment vont-ils réussir à
augmenter les charges diminuer les
impôts le tout dans un contexte
d'endettement italien extrêmement lourd
est politique européenne de réduction
des déficits c'est possible cc c'est
mission impossible
mais cette situation cette situation
cette réponse de lentilles système on
vient de le dire dans ce reportage
c'est une pierre jetée dans le système
le système comment s'est il comporté par
rapport à ces migrations massives au nom
du respect de la souveraineté nationale
au nom du désaccord de dublin antérieure
aux migrations massives lesquels
migrations massives sont en partie la
conséquence de l'intervention de
certains européens lors des printemps
arabes en libye et en syrie
l'europe qui n'a pas tiré les
conséquences de l'engagement qu'elle
avait pu prendre et bien là on a laissé
les italiens se débrouiller seul face à
l'immigration
c'est un acte d'irresponsabilité de la
part de chefs d'état et de gouvernement
de l'union européenne
cette situation met en cause la
responsabilité
le déficit de vision commune
comme si l'europe n'était qu'une
addition d'égoïsmes nationaux
donc j'espère que cette situation va
créer un électrochoc et mettre en
évidence à quel point nous avons besoin
d'europe sur des domaines qui engagent
des prérogatives de souveraineté vient
un moment où du fait de la
mondialisation les états seuls n'ont
plus les moyens d'assumer certaines de
ces souveraineté et bien lorsqu'ils
n'ont plus les moyens d assumer
il n'ya que l'europe qui peut s'y
substituer et donc c'est souveraineté
doivent être partagées et on doit en
tirer les conséquences sur le plan
budgétaire
pourquoi on dit ici c'est une pierre
dans le jardin du système à système qui
a était autiste et aveugle qu'on l'a dit
le gouvernement italien et antisystème
eurosceptiques anti-immigration il
souhaite par la manière forte
expulsé les cinq cent mille clandestins
d'italie durcir les conditions d'asile
diminuer drastiquement le budget
d'accueil et démanteler les camps de
roms vous dites quoi eva joly
c'est un discours typiquement populiste
et sortir le chiffre de reconduites 500
mille migrants dans l'année lorsqu'il ne
reconduise qui simule par an c'est
évidemment complètement fictif mais je
suis tout à fait d'accord avec monsieur
arthuis pour dire que c'est un défaut de
solidarité européenne devant les crises
migratoires dont nous sommes en partie
responsable nous avons laissé par
remords avons laissé la grèce la grèce
et l'italie
seul avec parce qu'ils sont limitrophes
en méditerranée on se rappelle que la
commission avait décidé de rapatrier
160000 et de répartir 160 mille réfugiés
au sein de l'union
la france devait prendre vingt mille
nous en avons pris quatre mille
donc c'est une absence de solidarité est
pareil manche dirait la zone euro qui
est si importante
aujourd'hui avec la crise mondiale avec
la décision de trump de se retirer de la
corde et l'iran seul un euro fort
cam archer vivant permet de faire des
contrats en euros échappé à la
juridiction américaine
et nous ne pouvons pas nous payer une
crise de l'euro c'est très grave
dans le contexte international mais pour
cela il faut aussi une plus grande
solidarité au sein de la zone euro il
faut une gouvernance de la zone euro la
dette italienne est largement privé elle
est privée italienne et c'est peut-être
ce qui va faciliter un tout petit peu
les traitements de la crise on voit déjà
les taux d'intérêt qui augmente pas
répondu à ma question sur le plan
économique à vous avoir dérangé un
danger c'est une perte de confiance
c'est une fragilisation de l'euro si on
veut que l'on investisse en europe il
faut pas qu'ils aient le moindre doute
sur la pérennité sur la solidité sur la
confiance qu'inspire l'euro c'est en
cela que la gouvernance de la zone euro
doit être l'objet de toutes nos
attentions et qu'il y a urgence à ce que
l'on réforme cette gouvernance pour
qu'il y ait une véritable politique
économique à l'échelon et non pas une
addition de politique nationale
nous avons une monnaie unique avec une
banque centrale unique une politique
monétaire unique mais ya pas de
politique économique unique
donc ceci doit faire l'objet aussi d'une
réforme en profondeur cette situation
italienne devrait être l'électrochoc qui
va enfin faire bouger c'est convaincre
aussi bien l'opinion publique que les
chefs d'état et gouvernement qu'on ne
peut pas continuer ainsi qu'il y a
urgence être ni solidaire est ce que le
problème fondamentalement c'est pas que
les peuples européens sont
majoritairement eurosceptiques
aujourd'hui non les peuples européens
sont pas majoritairement eurosceptiques
mais il y à des discours démagogiques
qui donne des réponses des fausses
réponses mais rapide et qui font qu'à un
moment donné sur une élection nationale
en à ce type de vote
il va falloir faire très attention pour
l'élection européenne prochaine et pour
démontrer que d'autres options sont
possibles mais vraiment encore une fois
il faut faire jouer la démocratie
européenne
le conseil aujourd'hui n'avance pas mais
demain ce sera quoi avec l'italie qui va
arriver au sein du conseil on parle et
on est tous d'accord pour réformer la
zone euro et pour faire en sorte qu'il y
ait davantage de solidarité
mais avons-nous la certitude qu avec ce
gouvernement italien et les propositions
qui fait qu'ils iront dans ce sens là si
le parlement européen ne joue pas
pleinement son rôle comme nous le
proposons dans cette réforme de la zone
euro si on ne casse pas cette règle de
l'unanimité au sein du conseil et qu'on
ne revient pas à une règle de la
majorité on ne pourra pas avancer
en tout cas il y a dans ce peuple
européen une majorité et je veux encore
le croire
qui est pro européenne mais il faut
répondre à ces questions
eva joly avait raison nous avons voté au
parlement européen certain nombre de
propositions pour la relocalisation des
réfugiés pour la solidarité au sein de
l'union européenne
le conseil n'a pas respecté ses
engagements alors même qu'il était
d'accord il ya la france mais il n'ya
pas que la france qui à l'ensemble de
l'union européenne qui n'a pas respecté
cela et qui a laissé l'italie seule avec
ces réfugiés et qui a poussé des cris
d'allah
plusieurs fois je lis vos oncles que le
parlement européen quand ils votent des
lois elles soient respectés comme c'est
le cas en france
on voit aussi les dégâts d'une politique
d'austérité qui a vraiment été trop dur
pour les peuples et il est aussi temps
et ça ils ont raison il est aussi temps
de sortir de la politique d'austérité et
de trouver une politique qui s'occupe
aussi de l'intérêt des peuples et pas
simplement des investisseurs ou des
capitales et rapidement il ya sûrement
un déficit démocratique en europe c'est
la sphère des chefs d'état et de
gouvernement des gouvernements qu'ils
s'arrangent entre eux et qui d'ailleurs
qu'on vienne la budget qui est un budget
1% du produit intérieur brut de
l'ensemble de l'union européenne
c'est pas le budget d'une puissance
mondiale donc le vrai sujet maintenant
c'est d'engager le débat par des
conventions citoyenne sur ces questions
là quels sont les domaines dans lesquels
les états membres seuls n'ont plus
vraiment les moyens d'exercer leurs
prérogatives de souveraineté et si ce
constat est fait et bien il est temps
d'imaginer c'est vrai pour la défense
c'est vrai pour les climats c'est vrai
aussi pour les fraudes et les paradis
fiscaux et pour les données numériques à
l'est pas on passe à notre dossier du
jour une petite révolution cette semaine
gp des quatre lettres qui vont changer
votre vie privée gpd pour règlement
général prem protection des données
textes européens pour mieux protéger nos
données numériques 1 s'impose à tous les
européens à partir du 25 mai en quoi ce
texte protège t-il davantage notre vie
privée
le point avec phoenix eu l on l'appelle
l'or noir du 21e siècle
le traitement des données est un marché
aux perspectives démesurée qui pèse déjà
plus de 130 milliards d'euros un marché
que l'union européenne est décidée à
réguler voici donc le rgp dès le
règlement général de protection des
données
la première grande nouveauté du texte
c'est que les entreprises
étrangement pourront plus facilement
collecter vos données c'est le cas de
bio serenity une société spécialisée
dans les vêtements connecter pour les
malades
elle récolte donc des informations de
santé parfois très sensible
fondé il ya quatre ans l'entreprise a dû
attendre un an avant d'obtenir une
autorisation de la cnil
un processus qui va disparaître avec le
rg sinon il ya quelques années on
était contrainte d'attendre
l'autorisation afin de mettre en oeuvre
de produits avec le nouveau règlement en
fait on peut se suffire en fait d'une
simple déclaration
en contrepartie de cette liberté les
entreprises seront obligées d'être
totalement transparente sur
l'utilisation qu'elles font des données
le rgp des garanties en effet aux
citoyens européens
l'accès la rectification et la
suppression de ces informations
personnelles à bio serenity pour cela
depuis un an on a désigné une déléguée à
la protection des fichiers
ça c'est notre exemplaire papier de
verre gpd on a plusieurs fois tu sûr que
con
on a toujours un sous la main quand on a
besoin c'est un post obligatoire pour
les entreprises qui gèrent beaucoup de
données je m'occupe de recenser les
traitements de données personnelles est
de m'assurer que la manière dont on
traite les données personnelles en
interne est conforme à la législation
rgp des et aux législations nationales
autre grande nouveauté le principe de
proportionnalité
en clair il faut que la récolte des
données soit en adéquation avec
l'objectif recherché par l'entreprise
prenons par exemple les applications de
lampes torches certaines demandes accès
aux données de la caméra rien d'anormal
la lampe torche fonctionne avec le flash
du téléphone plus surprenant certaines
applications souhaite également accéder
à nos photos à nos informations sur les
wifi utilisées et même à l'historique de
nos appels rien à voir donc avec la
simple fonction de lampe torche
cette application ne pourra plus être
proposé en europe
dernier grand changement avec la lutte
contre le piratage
si une entreprise se fait voler des
données elle devra le signaler aux
autorités
voir à ses clients une situation comme
celle qu hubert a connu en 2016 ne
serait plus possible
la société californienne s'étaient fait
pirater les données de 57 millions de
clients à l'époque elle n'avait rien dit
et aurait préféré payer une rançon
la plupart des chefs d'entreprises
français se félicite du rgp d mais ils
s'inquiètent et toutes ces règles ne
vont-elles pas les pénaliser face à des
pays aux législations beaucoup plus
souple certains députés ayant travaillé
sur le texte les ont rencontrés pour
écouter leurs doléances
je vais être obligé d'avoir une version
un peu différente pour les etats-unis
que ce que ce que je vais avoir pour
l'europe
ou alors ça veut dire que je bride les
états unis alors l'optimisme des députés
en disant mais les américains vont aussi
comprendre un jour la protection des
données privées etc
et puis ça finira par parler dans le
même sens que nous je le souhaite mais
moi j'attends de voir je suis pas j'ai
pas demain aujourd'hui on a en en avance
c'est pas toujours le cas au niveau du
mec par rapport aux états unis ouais je
pense qu'il faut qu'on continue de façon
positive et que les citoyens américains
eux vont aussi demander plus de sécurité
de leurs données en cas de non-respect
du rgp des sur le sol européen
les contraventions pourront grimper
jusqu'à 20 millions d'euros ou 4 % du
chiffre d'affaires mondial de
l'entreprise
alors portage de félix ul eva joly à des
données personnelles mieux protéger là
il ya des sanctions
ça change tout ça va changer quoi pour
nos concitoyens européens pu mais lassé
des vraies sanctions parce que ça peut
donc attendre 4 % du chiffre d'affaires
au kac tuellement les amendes étaient de
l'ordre de 100 mille euros 150000 euros
dans ces deux joueurs wii donc
maintenance est incommensurablement plus
important c'est donc une législation
très protectrice de nos données c'est la
meilleure au monde c'est l'europe qui
protège c'est la portabilité par exemple
de donner c'est la possibilité d'avoir
accès aux données de les corriger s'ils
sont erronés et c'est le droit est
informé si l'entreprise a eu des
difficultés on se rappelle que yao s'est
fait pirater 5 un demi milliard de
comptes en 2014
et elle n'a prévenu que deux années
après là aujourd'hui ce n'est plus
possible il est susan rice ont informé
en temps réel et peuvent prendre des
précautions donc c'est une très bonne
régulation
elle va être mise en oeuvre en france
par la cnil et donc il est important
maintenant que la cnil soit doté des
moyens à la hauteur de sa nouvelle
mission
pour le moment ce n'est pas encore le
cas mais je compte sur le prochain
budget pour augmenter ses effectifs et
et ses crédits mais il redonne c'est un
grand pas vers la protection des
européens
c'est tellement un grand pas que quand
mark zuckerberg avant qui viennent
devant nous de vence 6000 il été entendu
et audi s'il était entendu mardi au
vaincu s'excuser à abbey s'est excusé
mais il n'a pas répondu aux questions
parce que le format ne permettait pas
qu'il réponde aux questions et donc
maintenant on est juste dans la tente de
les rêves des réponses aux questions
écrites que nous allons lui adresser
avant lui disais que le verger pdl et tu
internet maintenant il dit que c'est
c'est bien donc il ya une avancée csssae
avant avant de venir devant le parlement
européen quand il est allé devant le
sénat américain
les sénateurs américains disaient mais
il faudrait que nous ayons un règlement
du type du rgp des européens aujourd'hui
l'exemple européen et démontré partout
au sein de dans le monde entier parce
qu'on a mis un cadre à la fois de
protection mais aussi effectivement de
sanctions ce montant de sanctions était
très important à mettre en place ces 20
millions c'est énorme
parce que tant qu'on était sur des
montants à la hauteur de 150 milles ça
coûtait finalement très peu et ça
n'empêchait pas ses entreprises de
continuer à utiliser nos données nous
étions des produits et pas des individus
donc là on a ce cadre de protection
c'est important genre genre tu es on l'a
vu dans le reportage à toutes ces règles
est ce qu'elles vont pas pénalisés
les entreprises à face à des pays aux
législations un peu un peu plus souple
existe il faut une europe qui nous
protège et donc si nous imposons en
europe des règles qui sont des
suppléments de dépenses pour notamment
les entreprises qui opèrent en europe et
qui doivent être compétitive et bien ça
suppose que nous prenions des
régulations dans les traités de libre
échange qui compense le poids des
contraintes que nous imposons mais ce
qui me paraît très important ici je
partage tout à fait et les avis comptent
exprimer mais mes collègues c'est que
nous sommes en face de qui nous sommes
en face des géants du numérique d'apple
facebook amazon
il est clair que les états membres seul
ne pèse pas lourd
et d'ailleurs les européens se rendent
bien compte puisque ils se concurrencent
mutuellement pour permettre à ces géants
du numérique de ne pas payer d'impôts en
europe
ce qui est stupéfiant en quelque sorte
et comment se fait-il qu'il n'y ait pas
de géants du numérique en europe
et bien parce que l'europe a été d'un
laxisme total là nous avons un bel
exemple de ce que peuvent accomplir les
européens lorsqu'ils su niche
ils font le poids par rapport à
l'impérialisme des géants du numérique
donc ceci est très prometteur et devrait
convaincre tous les eurosceptiques que
face à de tels enjeux à de tels défis
que nous lance la mondialisation il n'y
a pas d'alternative à l'union européenne
eva joly a eu le scandale de la firme
cambridge analytique a un qui a pu dans
hawx et irma qui a pu exploiter à leur
insu les données de dizaines de millions
d'utilisateurs de facebook a pour une
utilisation à des fins politiques qu'ils
en trouvent dans la campagne de donald
trump est ce que ce scandale peut
arriver avec avec ce rg pdc justement
c'était c'est des bornes parce que
maintenant il faut l'accord des
titulaires du compte facebook par
exemple pour que les données soient
exploités et je ne vois pas les citoyens
de donner leur accord pour influencer la
campagne électorale
en amérique ou en grande bretagne
parce que cambridge analytica a aussi
influencé le référendum sur le break
site et donc on voit bien combien c'est
dangereux
délaissé les opérateurs disposer
librement de nos données c'est quelque
chose qui atténue la démocratie au coeur
donc vraiment c'est ce règlement général
de protection de données est très
important allez on passe à notre
rubrique de fact checking exemples
concrets à grâce aux rg aurez-vous le
droit d'accéder au mail de votre patron
qui parle de vous c'est checkpoint
préparé par ambroise carton aujourd'hui
[Musique]
quelles sont les données collectées par
les entreprises le nouveau règlement
européen sur la protection des données
personnelles devraient permettre d'y
voir plus clair
le citoyen grâce à ce règlement vous
allez pouvoir reprendre en main vos
données vos données qui sont aujourd'hui
stockées chez des fournisseurs en ligne
de plate-forme en ligne des sites en
ligne et toutes ces données et bien vous
allez pouvoir leur demander de vous les
envoyez les consommateurs seront donc
mieux informés sur l'utilisation que de
grandes entreprises comme google
facebook ou amazon font de leurs données
mais pourra-t-on vraiment tout savoir
selon le quotidien britannique the
guardian si un travailleur en fait la
demande
l'employeur devra lui fournir une copie
des données qu'il détient en ce compris
tous les emails où il est question de
l'employé vrai ou faux
[Musique]
quand anton par données personnelles en
résumé ce sont toutes les informations
liées à une personne physique par
exemple ce qu'on trouve sur sa carte
d'identité
sinon son adresse mais aussi un numéro
de téléphone ou une adresse email le rg
est une sorte de piqûre de rappel en
belgique et en france cela fait
longtemps qu'on peut demander l'accès à
ses propres données
mais c'était parfois un parcours du
combattant ce qui est nouveau c'est la
mende pour les entreprises qui ne
respectent pas les règles il pète
astronomique 1 4% du chiffre d'affaires
mondial
cela ne veut pas dire qu'on pourra
accéder absolument tout pour en être sûr
on a envoyé un e-mail à la commission
belge de la protection de la vie privée
et ils ont répondu ceci le droit
d'accéder pas illimitée il devra
également être tenu compte d'autres
obligations telles que la
confidentialité des communications
ou la sécurité nationale et public tout
ça se retrouve d'ailleurs à l'article 23
du berger et si l'employeur et
l'employé ne sont pas d'accord ils
pourront demander un juge de trancher
donc c'est vrai le but du rgp des biens
de faciliter l'accès aux données
personnelles en europe mais avec
certaines limites quand même voilà un
vrai le rgp des protège les données
personnelles et faux seins les courriels
personnels de votre employeur a même si
votre nom est cité un les mails sont du
domaine de la correspondance à un privé
donc vous n'y avez pas accès il ya donc
des limites à à la transparence
eva joly la confidentialité des
communications et la sécurité nationale
et public
oui c'est cet homme toute chose s'il y a
le principe et puis il y à d'autres
considérations comme la sécurité
nationale la défense est aussi le les
secrets de l'employeur aujourd'hui
comment vous expliquez que la majorité
des entreprises françaises n'est pas
encore prête pour appliquer le verger
faut laisser du temps
c'est souvent le cas c'est souvent le
cas il ya des règlements car il ya des
directives qui sont votées mais on
attend le dernier moment
donc ce que je crois ce qu'il faudra
certainement quelques mois pour être la
hauteur d'un objectif qui est visé mais
la démarche est une démarche salutaire
reprendre en main ces données
personnelles c'est reprendre en main son
destin
la protection est totale est ce qu'une
information qu'on donne maintenant
exemples concrets à facebook est ce que
ça peut être exploitée par des grandes
centrales de sécurité comme la cia la
nsa et yahia la question de sécurité
nationale qui effectivement qui doit
être mise de côté parce que ça on peut
quand même pas revenir dessus mais il ya
peut-être quand même des fois où la cia
où ces organismes là vont au-delà de ce
que la loi leur autorise de faire donc
il faut que sur ce qui est du droit
commun il relève effectivement du droit
commun et pour ce qui est de toutes les
considérations liées à leur mission il
est il continue à avancer mais vous je
voulais juste rebondir sur une chose
vous disiez les entreprises ne sont
peut-être pas encore prête ça fait juste
deux ans qu'on l'a votée au parlement
européen donc tout le monde le savait
que ça arrivait et il y aura un nouveau
texte européen qui sera très important
qui va conforter le rg pdc le iie
privacy avec ces deux éléments là on
devrait être protégé le mode afin la
cnil a déclaré que la première année
c'est l'accompagnement et que ce n'est
pas les sanctions sa première
préoccupation dans les mois à venir tant
que je pense que les entreprises peuvent
être rassurées vous pensiez il mettre en
place les structures vous pensez que le
rgp des européens va faire des bébés aux
états unis en asie mais qui en est
partout d'hommes il faudrait qu'ils une
protection des données partout dans le
monde et là ce sera le mot de l'afssa ça
dépend des valeurs les valeurs
fondamentales de l'europe et l europe ne
doit être emblématique c'est le respect
des libertés publiques de la démocratie
de l'état de droit de l'indépendance de
la presse
on les respecte à ses valeurs aux
etats-unis non oui mais j'aurais qu en
europe pour les respecte également en
tout cas merci à vous trois d'être venus
débattre avec nous c'était passionnant
merci à vous de nous voit de nous avoir
suivis à la semaine prochaine pour tour
il n'aura hamadi même endroit même heure
1 d'ici là bonne suite des programmes
sur les chaînes parlementaires et la
rtbf bail
[Musique]